hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website calm today we're going to
be going over the pons eonni opening
lately it has been the most requested
video that I make so for any of you out
there wondering if you email me or leave
me a comment that lets me know the video
want me to make does it actually matter
do I read those I most definitely do so
for the many many people who have asked
for the pons eonni opening today we're
going to go ahead and get into that I'm
going to try to make the most
comprehensive video online I've been
looking at a few of them just to kind of
see what's out there because I
definitely don't want to duplicate
anything out there happy to say that
this is going to be the best pons eonni
opening video that's available online so
if you're not too familiar with Ponzi on
the opening starts with pani for pani 5
9 f3 simple development from white
trying to control the center and get as
minor pieces involved into the game same
with black here Knight to c6 now from
here there are three options at white
has we do have the right Lopez which is
Bishop to b5 we also have the Italian
game which is Bishop to c4 and we have
the Ponzi on the opening that we're
going to be going over today and that is
pawn to c3 now do keep in mind I'm not
trying to convince you that the Ponzi on
the opening is better than the Rui Lopez
or it's better thee and then the Italian
game in fact it's actually easier for
black to you know to neutralize to
equalize the game easier in the Ponzi on
the opening so you don't need to leave a
comment and say why would anyone play
the Ponzi on the opening I can't believe
you made this video I'm simply making it
because one there's a lot of different
traps that white has and black can get
into a lot of trouble and I don't think
it's played enough really and it's not
really you know study that much at high
levels of play to actually say that it's
a terrible opening so I've played it
many times myself I've played again it
against it many times myself
if anything I think it's very very
important for chess players to know
about so that's why we're going to be
going over today and again the Ponzi on
opening starts with pawn to c3 that's
where we're going to be spending our
time today now from here black has three
main options two of which which you
see over and over and then a third one
which I throw in because it's actually
the line that I play it's the most
aggressive not really going to say it's
the best but it does catch opponents off
guard so I thought I'd throw it in there
for those of you who are like I wonder
what Kevin Duke would do in this
situation so from there we do have three
options black does have Knight to f6
which you'll see very often try to
control the center of the board also
trying to develop one of his minor
pieces towards the center always a good
idea you also have the sharp line which
is the d5 just thrusting forward trying
to control the center of the board wide
again you know somewhat passive with
this c3 move
you know blocking off the you know
development square here for the night
coming to c3 obviously with this pawn
here on c3 later on the game the night
probably is going to be coming too
Knight to d2 which isn't typically a bad
thing you know it blocks it from c3 but
it's still going to get into the game so
don't sit here and think out of this c3
square
you know the knight will never get
involved he definitely will so white
kind of loses some tempo here with the
pawn to c3 but why should we look into
thrust forward with his pawn here on d4
so just keep that in mind really doesn't
matter where black is going to go why
it's going to be thrusting forward with
pawn to d4 at some point in the
variation so we do have d5 and then the
last one the most aggressive that you
may see black play if you ever see me on
chest common we're playing you will
actually see me playing pawn to f5 now
again not saying this is bad worse
better but obviously you may see this
gambit here kind of a plays similar to
the Latvian gambit if you're familiar
with that gambit you know pretty fun
gamete to play so we do have that option
first option we are going to be looking
at is Knight to f6 this you're going to
see more times than not I think it's a
fine defense from black definitely gives
him a lot of options but there's so many
different things that white can do in
this game as well as black can do that I
definitely want to go over this first
now from here why it's going to continue
as we talked about and he's going to
play pawn to d4 now from here and I'm
actually going to be saying this
quite often in the video black has many
different options you may have to go
back pulls it right down some of these
have your chessboard out if you want to
make sure that you're getting all the
different variations but black
definitely has a lot of different
options here one of his options he has
he can come down and he can take on e4
he can also if he wants to he can just
come in and take here on d4 with his
pawn or he can always try and just push
his pawn forward with d5 and tried to
really attack the center of the board
here with his pawns the first one we're
going to talk about is Knight takes on
e4 again white is gambling off this
white pawn on e4 gambit simply means
that we're going to give up material for
some reason that could be to gain you
know a tempo it could be to gain
development it could be to checkmate our
opponent the next move but we're going
to be gambling off this pawn here on e4
for the time being now from here black
has a few different moves but really the
only move that you're going to be
playing is pawn to d5 trying to chase
this night away now keep in mind he
really has two main options you're not
really going to see Knight to b4 or
Knight to a5 you're really going to be
seeing at night to b8 and you also may
see Knight to e7 now both have their
pros and cons so I do want to go over
each of those Knight to e7 as you can
see really starts to hinder the
development of you know the black pieces
we can see here that this dark square
Bishop on f8 is going to have a very
hard time developing into the game so
it's kind of blocking himself off also
he is really hampering this Queen here
on d8 White's campus kind of opened up
he can get both of his like square
bishop and his dark squared bishop
involved into the game at any time he
can bring his knight to d2 really start
to develop him and his queen is also he
can be very active he has this diagonal
you know here to d4 or excuse me
a4 and he also has this D file that he
can work with so this is kind of
cramping black style but so many people
don't want to also come back to b8 and
say you know what I move
and then I just moved back I kind of
wasted a move here so tempo wise black
is down again white gave up material so
this is kind of what he wants he either
wants to be up in development have an
extra tempo or he wants to kind of block
off blacks move with that Knight to e7
so as far as how to attack this
obviously we would not only want to know
where black could go but how we can
attack this so from here White's
actually going to play Bishop to e3 and
you look at this and you say you know
Kevin why don't we just take back this
pawn here on e5 and that's a great
question but but really we're going to
but this is kind of an in-between move
here with Bishop to e3 and we're kind of
allowing black to hang himself there's
so many different ways that black can
hurt himself that I really like this
move Bishop to e3 here now currently
black has one thing going for him he is
up in material so what he really needs
to do he actually needs to hold on to
that material advantage now this pawn
here on e5 is hanging right now we are
attacking it or White's attacking it
with this night here on f3 so black
would really like to reinforce this pawn
here on e5 now he does have a few
options he can always bring a pawn down
to f6 he can always bring a pawn to d6
he can bring his Queen to e7 or he can
always bring his Bishop to d6 all of
these are going to defend the pawn here
on e5 now I didn't want to go over
because there are different things that
black can do to hang himself as we
talked about let's say he plays pawn to
f6 now from here white q can simply
continue to take here on e5 even though
black thinks he can retake now the Queen
can come back to h5 and the King has to
move obviously nothing can protect the
King so the King is going to have to
come to e7 the Queen now swoops in to e5
capturing and he's also attacking the
knight here on e5 so not only is the
King no longer safe no longer Kenny
castle no longer is black able to simple
develop any of its pieces why it's going
to take the only developed piece that
Black has any is going to be winning
very very easily in this game so as you
can see pawn to f6 is going to be a epic
fail for black now he also does have d6
which actually seems like a reasonable
move if you look at it you know getting
ready for his light square bishop to
come into the game you know again
supporting this pawn here on e5 but
white here could just come bring his
queen to a4 attack the King here on 8
and also forking the night here on e4 he
is going to win a lot of material here
and also we are taking the only
developed piece from black while White
has all this open space he has two minor
pieces and a major piece developed in
the center in the board and white is now
up in the material so d6 is also going
to be a very very bad move for black now
one of the better moves that black does
have is he can bring his bishop down to
d6 the only problem with this is it does
really cramp the style of black black
would really at some point obviously not
right always we talked about he would
like to start to move this pawn here on
d7 forward so he can get his light
squared bishop involved into the game
also you know he would like a little air
for his queen on d8 to move around but
what this does is it protects the pawn
here on e5 and it also allows black if
he wants to to castle on the Kings side
to get some sort of King side safety
before he really starts to you know get
his other pieces involved into the game
if you're up in material any time you
can have King safety doesn't matter if
it's on the King side or Queen side and
start to develop your pieces you're
going to be okay in the game problem
that you have if you're up in material
is a lot of times your King's exposed
you know the other person has all these
aggressive attacks or your pieces just
aren't developed and you're just behind
in tempos and things just go bad so this
is not a bad move for black here
although he does have some problem that
he's going to have to deal with later on
into the game
now from here White's going to play
Knight to d2 again we talked about any
time we have this pawn here on c3 which
we do in the Ponzi on the opening we're
now going to be bringing our
- D - now again we are attacking the
most developed piece here from black
here on e4 so if he captures if he takes
on D - our Knights now going to come
back to D - preparing for our Knight
coming to c4 again not only attacking
the pawn on e5 here but also attacking
the bishop there on d6 now from here
black cueing can as we talked about
castle on the kingside and why it's
going to play Knight to f4 now if you
were to run this through the engine even
though white is down in material he's
down one pawn the computer is actually
favored white in this position as far as
sooner control the board white is a
little bit ahead as far as open space
white can develop his pieces a lot more
easily than black hand he's also
attacking this bishop he can have a
bishop pair if he wants to later onto
the game it's going to be very very hard
you know for black to hold on to both
this bishop and this pawn here on e5 and
white should have a very very solid game
here so just keep that in mind this
particular situation is going to be very
very good for white now if we come back
here instead of the bishop coming to d6
the last option we talked about to
defend this pawn on e5 he can bring his
Queen to e7
now from here White's going to continue
with the same thing Knight to d2 but now
after black captures with his knight
he's now going to bring his Queen to d2
again before white really wanted to
recapture with his knight on D - so that
he could come to c4 and put a lot of
pressure on that Bishop that was on
these six the bishops no longer on d6 so
we can now recapture with our Queen on D
- white if he wants to he can now castle
on the Queen side really eyeing down on
this D thought of putting a lot of
pressure with his Queen and the rook or
if he wants to at any time he can
develop his LightSquared Bishop and
castle on the King side as you can see
here a black still going to have a hard
time his queen is blocking off his dark
square bishop so if your black in this
position it's going to be very very hard
for you to castle either way it's going
to be a few moves for you where white
can castle very easily and then start to
attack
so White has a lot of different options
and the computer again even though white
sounded material still favors White's
position now that was just if the knight
comes back to b8 black also does have
the opportunity as we talked about to
bring his knight back to e7 all those we
said before this does again hamper a lot
of the development that black has in the
game again black wants to control the
pawn these up in material but it again
he needs to really start to develop some
of his pieces and not really cramp the
style of all of his development from
here why it's going to continue he's
going to play Knight takes on e5 and
then black has a few options here his
best option is actually to bring his
knight and come to g6 ok but a lot of
times you may see him try to kick off
this night here on e5 which is going to
be a huge mistake you may see f6 and you
also may see d6 this is another one of
those opportunities that white is giving
black just to simply hang himself so d6
seems like a very very logical move
again getting ready for this
LightSquared Bishop to develop into the
game also trying to kick this Knight off
of a 5 you never really want Knights or
any other major minor pieces kind of
hanging out in your territory so d6
seems like a logical move but from here
white can play Bishop to b5 very very
powerful move again this is checked so
if for any reason black tries to stop it
you know Knight to c6 would be a mistake
because the pawn would take it granted
this would be a mistake in general if
you play d6 so doesn't really matter
what you play it's going to be a mistake
but from here for the pawn comes to c6
you know white can capture if he doesn't
recapture he can always you know play a
move like pawn to c7 you know a
discovered attack so if white just
decides to recapture he can recapture
with his pawn on you know b7 taking on
c6 now from here the knight can come in
to c6 attacking the Queen here you know
black has to bop shion's if he takes
here then Y it's going to fork this rook
here on a 8 so obviously that's going to
be very very good
for white also blacks going to have to
move his king or he could bring his
bishop into the action and again the
rook would fall here so if he does want
to later on castle on the Kings side
also he can also bring his queen down to
be six but now white can play Knight to
d4 again discovered attack on the King
here and also defending the bishop here
on b5 now black does have two different
options he can just play you know King
to d8 if he wanted to or he can always
play his Bishop to d7 either way it
doesn't really matter the king is going
to have to move he's going to be exposed
and he's no longer going to be able to
castle on either side the Queen side has
really opened up the game both the B and
the C files are gone for black so all
white would have to do is castle on the
King side here and then really start to
you know have a humongous attack on the
Queen side it's going to be very very
hard for an exposed King on the Queen
side for black to really really defend
himself so very very good option for
white and he's also going to be up in
material so just keep this in mind this
is going to be you know if he plays that
pawn to d6 that's definitely going to be
a mistake now he might not play pawn to
d6 he could also play pawn to f6 as we
talked about before but from here it's
very easy the knight can just come back
to c4 very very simple and as you can
see here black still is hampered and
development his dark squared Bishop
can't get out into the game his queen
can't move his lights where a bishop
can't move
you know his night here on e4 is kind of
hanging eventually he's going to have to
you know solidify that and protect this
and also the King side safety isn't is
in question now you know we can start to
put a lot of pressure on this square
here on h5 attack it but the King is
really going to have to castle on the
Queen side now to have some sort of
safety as we can already see from here
it's going to take a few moves for that
safety to come along so really the best
move from black here is if he plays
Knight
to g6 now from here if black-white wants
to continue he can always come to d4
again attacking this hanging knight on
e4 play may continue there are a few
variations but play may continue with a
queen coming to f6 and then after a few
exchanges then the knight can come to d2
and then with the solidification of the
night here on e6 then white can play
Knight to c4 again threatening this
night here on e5 and he can also
recapture with his bishop on c4 if he
wants to
again as far as the development in the
game as you can see both sides are equal
own material again the computer favors
white in this position right here so
while so many people say that you know
black can equalize very very easily in
the Ponzi on the opening that may be
true but why it has so many different
variations so many different traps that
he can set in so many different ways to
keep his advantage it's actually not a
bad opening at all so some of the things
to keep in mind again that is if the
knight comes back to b8 and if it comes
back to e7 now those were the variations
if black played Knight takes on e4 as we
talked about before now we're going to
be talking about if black takes here on
d4
now from here White's going to push
forward he's going to play pawn to e5
now black has two options in this
situation he can either play Knight to
e4 or he can also come into Knight to d5
so I definitely want to make sure that
we cover both of those options if he
comes down to Knight to e4 blacks now
excuse me why it's now going to play
Queen to e2 again attacking the knight
here on e4 anytime your opponent has his
Knight coming to this fourth rank here
really getting to your territory you
really want to attack it so he can
really start to commit and you know try
to defend that night by any different
variation that he wants to now black
does have two different options here he
can solidify this he can always move it
back if he wants to you know obviously
his real
the only move would be Knight to c5
which I think would be a mistake you
know obviously you can't come back to d6
he would lose it or f6 you would move it
lose it even if he brought it back to g5
we have both our Bishop on c1 and our
knight on f3 attacking that but black
could try to solidify it with either
pawn to d5 or the pawn coming to f5 now
if the pawn comes down to F trot f5
excuse me simple development move from
black then white can play on passant so
pawn takes on d6 now again before anyone
makes a comment it says Kevin that's an
illegal move I've never heard of on
passant so it can't be true you can
actually capture like this if you really
want to know how it works you can just
google or Wikipedia on passant but if
you're on the fifth rank if for white
and black moves up to moves you can
capture like this that's not an illegal
move that's legal so from here black can
continue again and try to solidify this
this night here on e4 and then here
white can play Knight capturing on d4
and then if black wants to he can
recapture with his knight and then the
pawn is going to recapture here on d4
this is going to be a very very good
game for white as well so that's one
option he can also if he wanted to first
come down and solidify with his pawn on
f5 and then after on passant here then
the pawn can come down to d5 and again
as we talked about before the knight can
come to d4 capture and we're going to
kind of have some of the same game now
as you can see here at any time white
can push forward sacrifice another pawn
to force out this King to take on f7
obviously the King if you wanted to
could come to d7 you could also come to
e7 but any time white does have the
opportunity if it's not taken right away
to push forward to f7 just to kind of
draw out the King which is always fun
just if you want to just start attacking
your opponent's king you can always push
forward with the pawn here on f7 so
again this is going to be what happens
if black captures
as we talked about before in the Ponzi
on the opening if he captures with his
pawn on d4 excuse me with his pawn on d4
compared to if he captures with his
night here on f6 and takes here on e4
now last option that black has after he
plays Knight to f6 and white pushes
forward with his pawn to d4 getting very
common as we talked about he can also
thrust forward with pawn to d5 again
very very aggressive move from black
very sharp lines in this variation
trying to counter-attack the center
really trying to test white to see if he
studies his lines to see who is really
going to come out on top now from here
why it's going to play a Bishop to b5
pinning down this night here on c6
really trying to figure out what black
is going to do again this night here on
c6 is a well-developed move but it's
also defending this pawn here on e5 and
it's also attacking the pawn here on d4
so anytime you can develop your pieces
in this case we're developing our Bishop
our LightSquared Bishop allowing our
King castle on the King side but also
removing this defender because this is a
night here on c6 can no longer come into
the action to d4 or on e5 so from here
black does have a few options he can
always take with his pawn here on e4
from here white can push forward with
his pawn you'll see this a lot in the
Ponzi on the opening anytime one of the
pieces moves you're going to push
forward and try to kick this night away
now the knight from here is going to
come down to e4 and then why it's going
to recapture with his night here on d4
again putting a lot of pressure on this
knight on c6 and hit this knight is also
being pinned down to the King here on e8
now he doesn't have to take with his
pawn on e5 he could also be wants to
capture on as we can see here on e4 as
well
so from here White's now going to take
on e5 now he is putting a lot of
pressure on this night here on ACE on c6
if wipe you know black want to come in
and kick that Bishop off you could
always come down to a6 after the
exchange here
then the Queen can now come into a five
and put a lot of pressure on this pawn
on c6 so again black has doubled pawns
here he doesn't have a pawn on the B or
the D file this is going to be a very
very good game from white so again
there's so many different variations so
it's very very important that you
understand all the different ways that
black can attack you and how to counter
attack those as well the last one I do
want to talk about again the what the
knight can't come down and capture on d4
but the knight on f6 can come down and
capture with his knight taking on e4
from here White's going to continue do
the same thing he's going to take with
his nights here on e5 putting a lot of
pressure again on this knight on c6 if
black wants to play his Bishop to d7 you
know again trying to break this pin that
the bishop has then after the exchange
this is not about exchange for white at
all after the exchange same thing as we
talked about before white can castle on
the King side and black does have these
double pawns here on the C file so again
this is still going to be a very very
good game from white he can start to get
his knight developed excuse me his rook
developed to the e-file this open file
obviously black is going to get his arc
squared bishop involved into the game
castle on the King side but white should
have a very very good game from here as
well so that's going to happen if the
black side decides to push forward with
his pawn to d5 now those are quite a few
variations those are all for if black
plays Knight to f6 black again does not
have to play Knight to f6 one of the
sharpest moves and again one of the most
popular moves second only to Knight to
f6 is actually pawn to d5 a very very
sharp line from black probably one of
the sharpest that he can play in this
situation - the gambit here on f5 now
from here what's going to do the same
thing so very very common theme whereas
before white and black had a lot of
different options this one's going to be
a little bit more straightforward the
Queen's now going to come to
a four and he's going to try to pin down
this night here on c6 to the king he's
also going to try to protect this pawn
here on e4 if he doesn't have to he
really doesn't want to play a move
you know like Bishop to d3 you know
really hampering his you know
dark-squared bishop development can't
really move his pawn for a while if he
doesn't have to his first move he really
doesn't want to be pawn to d3 if he
doesn't have to you know simply because
he is now blocking off his LightSquared
bishop development so instead he's now
going to bring his queen to a4 again be
aggressive sometimes in this case you
definitely need to be aggressive you
know again pinning down this night and
also defending this pawn here on e4 now
from here black kin he can do one of a
couple things he can bring his queen
down to d6 if he wanted to
from here white can start to you know
try to harass this Queen here on d6 he
can play Knight to a3 getting ready for
his knight to come to b5 black can now
start to put more pressure
he can play Knight to f6 again really
starting to attack this pawn here on e4
white now has to play and Knight to b5
trying to distract this Queen on d6
after the Queen moves and now you know
white can play pawn to d3 so again you
know from here white can always bring
his Bishop to e2 castle on the King side
if he wants to he's a little bit weak in
his pawn structure but he can still have
a very very good game from here now if
we come back a few moves I'll just go
through them again after d5 here and the
Queen comes to f4 now the bishop can
also come to d7 you may not see the
Queen come down to d6 a lot of people
like to deal with you know a pin down
Knight which is bringing their Bishop
down to D 7 so if you do see this
instead we can now just play pawn takes
on d5 now it does get very very crazy
because black can now play Knight to d4
so this is a very very aggressive line
from black as you can see he's hanging
his knight here on the 4
but he's also has a discovered attack
with you know his Bishop Iran d7 on this
Queen here on a5 so again very very
aggressive line from black this is going
to be very very sharp so anytime you see
black play d5 at the beginning it's
going to be very very sharp line so just
keep that in the back your mind when you
are playing so again he doesn't have to
play d5 the last variation I do want to
talk about is the gambit the f5 move so
given the game it from here it plays
very similar to the Latvian gambit in
some respects but it's just pawn to f4
now I've actually played this a few
times against people that have tried the
pawn gianni opening and a couple moves a
couple the games are actually in person
a couple more online when I play these
in person I kind of got to look like I
don't know what you were doing but
you're either really good or you are
just straight bad at chess so it's
always fun to play a move like that just
to get that reaction from here after
white takes on f5 then the black Queen
can come down to f6 again putting a lot
of pressure on this f5 Square and he's
also you know trying to attack and
control this long dark diagonal now from
here white has a few options more than
likely he's going to play pawn to d5 or
excuse me pawn to d4 again that's the
main reason that white plays pawn to c3
is really to thrust forward with his
pawn to d4 again he has not only this
pawn on c3 he has this night here on f3
protecting and he also has the Queen
here on d1 so there's no reason for him
not to try to control all the dark
squares of the center of the board with
pawn to d4 now from here blacks going to
just start pushing forward he's going to
play pawn to e4 again as we talked about
main theme in the pawns eonni
opening both sides trying to push
forward trying to you know move those
Knights off of those critical squares of
you know c6 f6f-3 and these c3 squares
so from here why it's going to have to
move he can bring his knight to a g5
probably the best square form it is very
very aggressive and it's also being
defended by the bishop here on c1 so
really there's no reason not to you
definitely don't want to bring him back
to D to hinder the
development of your minor and major
pieces and you definitely don't want to
bring them back to g1
you know after you develop your pieces
if you don't have to you don't want to
bring them back to the square they came
from now from here black does have a few
options but his best move is just to
play pawn to d5 and this does a few
things first it opens up the door for
his LightSquared bishop to get involved
into the game it also solidifies this
pawn here on e4 this becomes a very very
powerful pawn for black later onto the
game it's also being attacked by the
knight here on G 5 so he needs to not
only solidify this but he also needs to
put more pressure on this pawn here on
f5 now keep in mind white is up in
material black gamed it off a pawn on f5
so white has a few options he can give
up this pawn he can give it back to
black or he can try to hold on to it so
again it doesn't really matter which way
white wants to go if he does want to try
to hold on to it he can play pawn to g4
again LightSquared bishop can no longer
come in and take it he is being defended
by the pawn here on g4 this starts to
get really crazy there's not too much
theory on it but black and out can play
pawn to h5 and it just gets messy from
here just chaos all over the board as
you can see whites no longer going to be
able to safely castle on the King side
you know later on he could try to castle
on the Queen side but it's not that safe
as well black pretty much has given up
on castle on the Kings side he can
always castle on the Queen side he is
down the material but he's really trying
to break up this pawn structure right
here that he has trying to control this
f5 square so there's so many different
sharp lines this is just a fantastic
game to play I've come to this exact
position quite a few times when I plays
black and Ponzi on the opening and I can
tell you from firsthand experience
there's just fireworks all over the
board so this is the Ponzi on the
opening I know there was a lot of
different variations I wanted to make
sure I covered everything to make sure
that if you're white or black that you
don't fall into traps that you know
exactly what you're looking for that you
don't have to think a lot of you know
different lines where should I be going
you know exactly what to do feel free to
try it out I know many people will tell
you
it's a terrible opening again I'm not
trying to tell you it's the greatest
opening ever or you know GM should be
playing it every time they play chess
but I do think it's important to know
and I think you know you can have great
success if you know exactly what you're
doing in the Ponzi on the opening so
feel free to play around let me know
what you guys think tell me if you have
success or failures with it also again
if you have a video that you want to see
whether it's me playing whether it's
commentating other games where that's an
opening whether it's you know deep
analysis of various lines as we did in
the Sicilian definitely let me know I
have a list of moves videos that I want
to make but if people let me know of a
very specific one definitely feel free
let me know and I'll definitely make
sure that I make that you guys haven't
already again check out the website the
chess website calm and I'll see you guys
in the next video
thanks for watching